kollegen meine damen und herren dies ist
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit die letzte
sitzung des deutschen bundestages in
dieser legislaturperiode und gerade in
den letzten tagen haben wir es mit sehr
dramatischen problemen zu tun eben ist
das thema afghanistan hier genannt
wurden ich will die gelegenheit nutzen
da wir ja nach der letzten ausführlichen
debatte noch nicht die möglichkeit
hatten unseren soldatinnen und soldaten
die dort an dieser schwierigen
evakuierungs mission beteiligt waren ein
ganz herzliches dankeschön zu sagen das
war einer der schwierigsten einsätze
und da ist in der tat nicht gelungen ist
insbesondere im bereich der
entwicklungspolitik alles
schutzbedürftigen personen zu evakuieren
war es richtig dass der
bundesaußenminister auf eine reise
gegangen ist in die nachbarstaaten um
diese probleme zu besprechen wie wir aus
reisen auch in zukunft möglich machen
und unserer verantwortung nachkommen und
genauso war es richtig mit den
nachbarstaaten darüber zu reden wie wir
humanitäre probleme dort zu lösen helfen
genauso wie wir uns um die humanitäre
lage in afghanistan ganz besonders im
blick auf hunger und medizinische
versorgung weiter kümmern werden
ansonsten haben wir eine ausführliche
diskussion ja vor 14 tagen geführt und
was die sorgen im innenpolitischen
bereich anbelangt
genau wie prophezeit beim thema
afghanistan das größte debakel in der
außenpolitik von angela merkel und sie
sagt was alles richtig gelaufen ist
außenminister ist herumgereist man wird
sich um humanitäre aspekte kümmern das
größte debakel schöngeredet in wenigen
sekunden
wir werden die menschen die von dieser
schrecklichen furchtbar flut betroffen
sind nicht vergessen der wiederaufbau
wird jahre monate jahre dauern und
deshalb auch in den
und das habe ich zugesagt
und dieses flutkatastrophe hat natürlich
als extremwetterereignisse den fokus
noch einmal auf eines der drängendsten
themen unserer zeit geworfen nämlich auf
den kampf gegen den klimawandel
und deshalb will ich an dieser stelle
noch einmal darauf hinweisen dass wir
wichtige weichen gestellt haben in
dieser legislaturperiode als die
bundeskanzlerin wohl im jahr 2005 taten
wir zehn prozent der erzeugung von
da an dieser stelle fehlt mir genau das
worüber wir haben anfang der sendung
gesprochen haben es ist nett dass sie
sagt dass sie sich den menschen geholfen
wird den flutopfern aber der
katastrophenschutz hat versagt und vor
allem dass die ausflüchte dass die
menschen dort gelebt haben nicht
alarmiert wurden mit dem entsprechenden
ich hier von frau merkel er erwartet zu
sagen was wir im katastrophenschutz
verbessern könnte anstatt sie nur auf
den klimawandel hinzuweisen
[Musik]
zweitens haben wir die bepreisung von
co2 eingeführt ein marktwirtschaftliches
instrument mit dem wir auf die reduktion
von co2 viel besser reagieren können wir
haben inzwischen eine millionen
elektroautos wir haben den ausstieg aus
der braunkohle miteinander vereinbart im
übrigen im gesellschaftlichen konsens
eine ganz wichtige sache sein
klimaschutz kann nur dann gelingen wenn
die menschen im lande auch mitgenommen
werden und das war immer der ansatz der
großen koalition und das war auch
richtig so
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir alle
spüren ja und in den letzten jahren hat
das aus meiner sicht zugenommen dass die
welt eine welt in unruhe und im umbruch
ist und das völlig neue
herausforderungen uns beschäftigen und
natürlich auch deutschland beschäftigen
das ist terrorismus dass das cyber
kriminalität das ist die technologische
revolution der digitalisierung das ist
die ökonomische stärke von china und
neben dem klimawandel ist es vor allen
dingen die digitalisierung die unser
leben vollkommen verändert
und wir haben uns in dieser großen
koalition immer vorgenommen möglichst
viele menschen so wie es eben beim
klimawandel gesagt habe mitzunehmen auf
die sind bei diesen wandel und deshalb
war ein zentrales thema unserer arbeit
in den letzten jahren die
gleichwertigkeit der lebensverhältnisse
in ganz deutschland zu sichern und zwar
zwischen ost und west zwischen stadt und
land und eine vielzahl der maßnahmen der
bundesregierung hat sich genau mit
diesem thema
beschäftigt ich kann hier nur stieg
behörden verlagerungen insbesondere in
die neuen bundesländer
die bundeskanzlerin sagte sie wollte
gleichwertige lebensumstände in ganz
deutschland sicher besonders beim thema
digitalisierung nichts davon ist in
ihrer kanzlerschaft tatsächlich
geschehen wir sind immer noch das land
des faxgerätes wir sind das land der
funklöcher wir sind das land in dem man
durch keine autobahntunnel kann erfahren
kann ohne dass die handyverbindung
abbricht und kinder in deutschland sind
vor allem nicht gleichberechtigt bei der
frage wie 4 2-sieg zu schnellen
datenleitungen und digitalisierung haben
eines der großen versagen dieser
regierung
überhaupt lebt zu machen wir haben den
rechtsstaat gestärkt durch einen
einzigartigen aufbau von mehr personal
und mehr möglichkeiten und wir haben den
kampf gegen den extremismus insbesondere
den rechtsextremismus durchgeführt und
bei den großen thema digitalisierung
haben wir entscheidende fortschritte
erzielt will daran erinnern dass wir
inzwischen behördengänge dass wir
inzwischen verwaltungsleistungen digital
anbieten insbesondere die des bundes wir
haben den die infrastruktur ausgebaut
breitbandanschlüsse mehr als 50 megabit
pro sekunde waren am anfang dieser
legislaturperiode 80 prozent jetzt sind
es 94 prozent wir haben eine
verfügbarkeit von lte anschließenden
mobilfunk von über 99 prozent das sind
dinge die kann man benennen es gibt
kleine schwierigkeiten nach wie vor an
vielen stellen blaue flecken und ähnlich
ist aber meine damen und herren im
großen ganzen haben wir deutliche
fortschritte gemacht und das war richtig
mit dem digital ja spektakuläre
schönrednerei der kanzlerin hier beim
thema digitalisierung ihrer wirtschaft
zumindest nach peter altmaier sagt er
lässt sich wenn er im auto unterwegs ist
die keine ausländischen gesprächspartner
aufs handy stellen weil ihnen die
funklöcher und die abrechnung leitungen
so peinlich und die kanzlerin sagt hier
99 prozent abdeckung kleine graue
flecken aber ansonsten alles okay das
ist eine komplette fehleinschätzung die
leistung beim thema digitalisierung
[Musik]
forschung das ist die quelle unseres
wohlstands für die zukunft und deshalb
kann man sagen als wir 2005 als ich
bundeskanzlerin wurde waren die ausgaben
für forschung und entwicklung lagen bei
24 prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts
heute sind wir bei 3,05 prozent wir
haben deutliche planungssicherheit für
die zwanziger jahre durch pakte für
forschungs wissenschafts packte
exzellenz strategie und vieles mehr
und du magst dass
dem einen oder anderen sehr abstrakt
erscheinen aber das hat etwas mit
unserem wohlstand und mit unserem leben
zu tun und das haben wir in der pandemie
erlebt der erste bisher bis heute
zuverlässigste tests zum nachweis des
virus wurde bereits zu beginn der
pandemie in deutschland in der charité
in berlin entwickelt und einer der
überaus wirkungsvollen emma impfstoff
gegen das virus wurde auch in
deutschland entwickelt auch dank
langjähriger die zielgerichtete
forschungsförderung und nebenbei gesagt
natürlich ja hier hat die kanzlerin
vollkommen recht das klima was für
forschung in deutschland geschossen
worden ist hat tatsächlich dazu geführt
dass deutschland eine zentrale rolle
gespielt er bei der bekämpfung der
korona panelli erster test aus
deutschland der impfstoff für die ganze
welt aus deutschland das sind durchaus
politische umstände die für solche
forschungserfolge von der
merkel-regierung geschaffen wurden
der in deutschland seit ende dezember
letzten jahres geben würde bekam einen
impfstoff der aller notwendigen phasen
der klinischen prüfung und notwendigen
zulassungsverfahren durchlaufen hat wir
sind uns doch alle einig dass noch viel
mehr menschen davon überzeugt werden
müssen geimpft zu werden doch wenn wir
die menschen davon überzeugen wollen
dann hat das mit argumenten zu geschehen
und nicht mit zurückhaltend kommentiert
tiefen bildern von versuchs kann
schön dass man merke hier erwähnt das
ist ein argumenten zu geschehen hat und
nichtmitgliedern vom versuchskaninchen
da stimme ich zu aber eigentlich haben
wir doch schon längst eine impfpflicht
durch die hintertür in restaurants muss
man seinen ausweis vorzeigen weit muss
man den test war noch bezahlen ich finde
dass sie hier auf argumente hinzuweisen
das tut frau merkel doch selbst in die
freiheit zurück
menschen geimpft sind umso kleiner ist
die gefahr dass sich neue mutationen
bilden gegen die impfstoffe nicht mehr
wirken und so aus diesem grunde möchte
ich auch von dieser stelle heute noch
einmal alle die noch nicht geimpft sind
bitten lassen sie sich impfen sie
leisten damit für sich und unsere
gesamte gesellschaft einen ganz
wichtigen beitrag den weg aus dieser
familie zu sehen
ja man hat es nicht wirklich ganz stark
sinken hinter der maske aber spannend
gerade das bedröppelt gesicht von olaf
scholz als angela merkel sich ganz klar
gegen seine formulierung von den
versuchskaninchen den deutschen als
versuchskaninchen für den impfstoff
gewarnt dass angela merkel hat in den
wahlkampf eingestiegen und hat dem man
ordentlich eine verbreitete er sich als
dir legitimer nachfolger und erbe
positionieren will olaf scholz
mit dem wiederaufbau von in dieser ganz
speziellen situationen einen neuen weg
zu beschreiten und europa auch gut aus
dieser krise zu führen und das heute die
zahl der kurzarbeiter wieder unter einer
million liegt dass die arbeitslosigkeit
deutlich unter 2 5 millionen liegen
2005 war sie fünf millionen heute die
helfen das ist solide haushaltspolitik
und richtigen entscheidungen ab anämie
zu verdanken auf die große koalition
insgesamt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen in
weniger als drei wochen des
bundestagswahl sie ist eine besondere
wahl nicht nur weil sich erstmals seit
1949 kein amtierender bundeskanzler
beziehungsweise bundeskanzlerin um die
wiederwahl bewirbt sondern es ist auch
eine besondere wahl weil es in
schwierigsten zeiten eine
richtungsentscheidung für unser land ist
und es ist nicht egal wer dieses land
regiert
die bürgerinnen und
bürger haben in wenigen tagen die wahl
entweder eine regierung die mit spd und
grünen die unterstützung der linkspartei
in kauf nimmt zumindest sie nicht
ausschließt oder
[Applaus]
sag ja nur die wahrheit
zumindest nicht ausschließen
oder eine von cdu/csu und armin laschet
als bundeskanzler geführte
bundesregierung eine bundesregierung
film ist maß und mitte unser land in die
zukunft
und dabei geht es wahrlich nicht allein
um die außenpolitik die nato und europa
meine güte was für eine aufregung ich
bin seit 30 jahren über 30 jahre
mitglied dieses deutschen bundestags und
ich weiß nicht wo wenn nicht hier solche
fragen diskutiert werden müssen das ist
die herz aber der demokratie
[Applaus]
wir haben muss man sagen dann steigt
bundeskanzlerin hier trieb den wahlkampf
dorthin wo er hingehört bringt die
debatte dorthin wo sie hingehört nämlich
ins parlament da geht es jetzt hoch her
schämen sie sich habe ich dann glaube
ich aus den reihen der abgeordneten
gehört ich weiß nicht genau wofür die
kanzlerin die sich hier stehen soll denn
sie hat genau das getan was sie gesagt
hat die wahrheit gesagt es geht um eine
richtungsentscheidung zwischen union
oder einer koalition die sich von der
linkspartei unterstützen lassen würde
[Applaus]
der beste weg für unser land ist eine
cdu csu geführten bundesregierung mit
armin laschet als bundeskanzler denn
seine regierung stabilität
verlässlichkeit maß und mitte stehen und
das ist genau das was deutschland frei
perfekt vor
merkel hält gerade am ende noch mal
alles zu zeigen was sie drauf hat und
ich muss sagen wenn ich sie so sehr wie
gerade im ring wo sie über das herz der
demokratie spricht werde ich sie als
kannst du denn schon vermissen deswegen
macht es gut vormerken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einer stelle langweilig wird also ganz
neues format hier werden so weitermachen
blitz analysen aber machen wir mal einen
strich drunter das war eine rede die ich
eigentlich so nicht erwartet hätte man
hätte denken können das ist vielleicht
ihre letzte rede dort und das wird so
ein bisschen staatstragend werden aber
nein sie ist ja auch vielleicht das
letzte bataillon dass die cdu/csu noch
hat jetzt ja der kanzlerin ist offenbar
bewusst geworden es sieht ganz ganz ganz
eng aus für die union gerade und sie ist
nicht nur bundeskanzlerin
sie ist auch abgeordnete und die hat
heute ganz klar als abgeordnete
gesprochen sie sich voll in die
offensive gegangen anfangs hat sie
einige dinge aus meiner sicht auch
teilweise brutal schön geredet aus ihrer
kanzlerschaft aber dann teil 2 der rede
rein in die offensive gehen in den
infight gleich den ersten punch gesetz
gegen olaf scholz hat ihnen massiv
kritisiert für das wort
versuchskaninchen und es dann nochmal
nach gesetzt hat gesagt es geht hier um
eine richtungsentscheidung wollt ihr
olaf scholz der mit der linkspartei
regieren würde die raus aus der nato
will die nicht für das deutschland steht
was wir sind oder wollt ihr stabilität
und dann klar für armin laschet geworden
es ging hoch her im bundestag ist wurde
reingerufen es wurde hohoho gerufen ist
wurde ich glaube schämen sie sich wenn
ich das richtig gehört habe gerufen von
wem können wir nicht genau zuordnen da
aber das war mal
parlamentarische demokratie vom
allerfeinsten und da sieht man jetzt
aber auch wie sehr die union gerade
spürt das ist wirklich in diesen letzten
nicht einmal mehr drei wochen um alles
geht und wir konnten ja auch das
interessante die drei kandidaten
beobachten die reaktionen nena auf
merkels rede dort wir konnten beobachten
scholz der ist mit dem stuhl so hin und
her gefahren gerade auch als es dann um
ihn gegen als sei er angesprochen wurde
und wir haben armin laschet gesehen
welchen eindruck hat er auf dich gemacht
ich weiß also sagen
ja bedeutet das sollte jetzt ganz schön
also ich meine dass armin laschet sehr
souveränen eindruck gemacht und am
anfang hat er das fand ich etwas unnötig
da pro berbalk und herr scholz und
zugehöriger von seinen unterlagen
nachgeschaut da finde ich immer schon am
anfang sollte man direkt der kanzlerin
zu hören und sie anschauen aber
natürlich mein er musste sich heute über
nichts aufregendes war für ihn ja heute
perfekt und ich finde aber julian hatte
das schon so schön analysiert schweiz
als merkel erbe das ist ja dass auch
womit er weder stimmen kriegt und heute
halten ihn einfach mal schön abgewatscht
und ich teile die meinung komplett ich
fand auch das einzige was ich mich frage
julian ist war das heute eher eine rede
für die demokratie und gegen die
linkspartei oder für armin laschet ich
hatte das gefühl dass frau merkel
einfach wirklich angst vor dem links
druck hat und sich deswegen so weit
vorgewagt hat ja ich glaube dass man
natürlich diese dieses linke
schreckenszenario mit der linkspartei in
der cdu ganz klar als
wahlkampfthema identifizierte wir werden
sehen ob es funktioniert viele umfragen
deuten auch darauf hin dass es nicht
funktioniert weil zu viele menschen gar
keine angst mehr haben vor diesem linken
schreckensszenario das ist auch ein
bisschen ausgeruht lässt man das ist
eigentlich immer wieder gemacht es ist
oft genug gemacht und es ist auch ein
bisschen spät gekommen ist kam in dem
moment als man merkte die themen von
armin laschet zünden nicht dann jetzt
bitte laschet wählen damit die nicht
gewählt wären das muss man sagen immer
dass zeit schlechteste argument dabei
bestes argument oder beste strategie ich
überzeugung und meinen eigenen
argumenten wenn das nicht funktioniert
kann ich sagen der andere ist der feind
der andere ist die linke gefahr auch ein
möglicher weg im wahlkampf aber nicht
der beste weg diesen weg hat die cdu
jetzt gewählt die kanzlerin merkel
offenbar das ist der einzige weg den wir
noch haben denn die persönlichkeitswerte
von amina stadt werden nicht mehr
steigen und die themen von armin laschet
werden auch nicht mehr zünden in den
letzten drei wochen dh das einzige was
der union bleibt vor der linken gefahr
waren und das hat die kanzlerin heute
massiv gemacht hat sie sich erstaunlich
in den dienst der partei gestellt was
sie lange nicht mehr gemacht hatte wer
jetzt immer olaf scholz auch beobachtet
sieht man ja eigentlich wirklich keine
emotionen an der wird eigentlich als wie
teflon alles perlt an ihr ab heute sahen
ein bisschen reaktion macht ihr das
unruhig glaubt ihr oder
hinter sich weiter zurück beobachtet und
denkt sich lassen armin machen es gibt
zwei wege in diesem wahlkampf im moment
armin laschet hat schiff machen armin
laschet hat sich entschieden den
langweiligen wahlkampf den angela merkel
immer gefüttert zu kopieren olaf scholz
hat gesagt ich mach's konsequenter ich
komme hier einfach die kanzlerin olaf
scholz hat sich positioniert als der
legitime aber der kanzlerin jetzt hat
die kanzlerin offenbar sich entschieden
ihm da einen strich durch die rechnung
zu machen und watschten bei jeder
gelegenheit ab das ist nicht mein aber
es gibt gewaltige unterschiede man
sollte sich nicht mit so sachen wie
versuchskaninchen
versuchen irgendwelche zeichen angela
merkel macht klar dieser mann ist nicht
angela merkel das ist für olaf scholz
gefährlich obwohl was ich sagen muss bei
armin laschet ist ja ich finde er selber
ist mit schuld daran dass armin laschet
so schlecht dasteht weil ich meine viele
bürger fragen sich natürlich wenn ich
mal ist die partei hinter ihm steht wenn
jemand wie markus söder sich so klar
dagegen positioniert hatte ja am anfang
mit der gegenkandidatur da muss man
natürlich ganz klar sagen warum sollte
ich hingehen und da hat olaf scholz
natürlich einen vorteil er ist der beste
unter den ganzen glauben wenn man sich
anschaue
[Musik]